[Music]
thank you
let's it's actually probably let's do
the BYU tick tocks
the Bedrock probably truck hit a vape
hit by a car oh hit a vape are you
trying to die
um get hit by a truck I'll probably hit
a vape I don't want to get my bones
broken probably trapped oh gosh probably
The Vape like puke after her so it's
like not in me college paid for man I'd
have to say hit a vape because I feel
like I might die hit a vape truck yeah
it'd probably be the truck huh hit a
vape I would rather be hit by Yo God is
crazy yeah seriously believing in God is
crazy dude also she said I'd hit a vape
and then puke it up afterwards so it
wasn't in me
that's not the way that works you got
your systems all mixed up I think
she doesn't realize that you hit a vape
one time you're gonna turn into heat
that's what she's afraid of she's gonna
smoke that she'd be like schmunky
just like her clothes and start wrapping
around her face she's like what is this
what's your favorite potty drink milk
water chocolate milk juice water
Kool-Aid man I like cream soda water a
virgin Mimosa water a virgin Mimosa
virgin Mimosa just orange juice warm
milk chocolate milk chocolate milk
chocolate milk cream soda oh there's
that Kool-Aid Man
I'm not like these [ __ ] lames all
right Kool-Aid man cool beans you know I
sip on that awesome sauce all the time
uh okay hit a vapor talk to a black
person
yeah that's what I'm saying they're nice
until it comes to that
get a baby
hit a favor talk to a black person yeah
get hit by a truck yeah that wasn't that
wasn't an option
hahaha
eggnog I guess water I guess juice
I guess water right I'm in a club
sipping on an eggnog dude
post it up in the section just [ __ ]
nursing an eggnog just [ __ ] yeast
yeast and milk in a [ __ ] joke thick
as hell
I'm a white [ __ ] dude I like truly
water
that was good that was good just sitting
right in the middle I'm a white [ __ ]
dude I like truly it's like do you even
go here nah what is this
it's such a crazy thing to say at a
[ __ ] Mormon campus I'm a white [ __ ]
man I like truly
Sprite because I'm on the BYU campus
it's gonna be cookies and cream milk
Diet Coke root beer bro what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you just sin one time
Jesus Christ man my favorite swear
what's your favorite swear word darn it
I'm partial to Frick damn just hot damn
it's like hot damn probably [ __ ]
honestly I say dang it a lot I like hell
probably that fun I like it I like hell
like hell Frac Frick great [ __ ] dang it
I just like crap I don't know I say
fetch a lot the most
fetch I swear word I've never used his
last word so my favorite swear word is
ass I don't know probably [ __ ] probably
[ __ ] probably s word as well [ __ ] s word
man
s word probably [ __ ] the one I say in my
head the most is the s word probably
shiz sword and uh it's Japanese damn wow
what's your favorite race
all right play this one DNA test
the b word I don't want to swear I'm
half Irish
I sent that
this turns out I'm a frog
that [ __ ] even when I'm crying crazy oh
those are the girls that do anal spells
those are the freaks on campus yeah you
know Clarissa Mallory and Cindy
yeah they cuss dude yeah the ones that
say the b word all the time dude Mallory
hit me up she's like if you want an ATM
I'm down I'm like yo I like imagining
them like
regular people and regular sexual
promiscuity but it's all in their terms
and their world yeah yeah just match
with this chick on
Mormon tender
yeah it's been going pretty good she's a
total [ __ ] s-word you know what I'm
saying
is that what they were talking about
maybe I'm just
she's a total s word but like in a good
way like first night we kicked it she's
like you want an ATM I'm like no shot
Louis ATM for hours dude my my are you
talking about ATM yeah okay okay
the head of my penis was dusted and
pooped dude
[Laughter]
yeah dude my [ __ ] penis looking like
Augustus Gloop
laughs
my penis literally looked like I ate a
chocolate bar dude it was [ __ ] I was
in there
yeah and all the all the girls talking
about it too
yeah I had Mason over last night
honestly like wasn't as big as I was
expecting but it's okay
be ATM till like two in the morning
it was crazy my ass jigs were chafed
[Music]
zero fecal dust left on that
which that part was nice
the message was hanging out with some
Mormon dudes then you're just like
yeah I got my ass ate last night
this is the horror
yeah she was [ __ ] sucking my dick in
balls and she put her tongue right in my
ass I was like I like that
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] was crazy she just
I was like oh I'm Yours yeah
that girl licked my butt and took my
soul man I got down on one knee right
there I'm like I love you
yeah she sucked on my [ __ ] yeah
like like a space lock ate my [ __ ] like
jello homie
no no
I think I mentioned this before I grew
up with some Mormon kid he would like
run around and pretend to be Pikachu it
was really embarrassing okay
he would like make the noise in the face
and like pick a pika yeah okay and he'd
pretend to shoot electricity walls okay
we were in
like second grade it was too late for
all that
we're playing handball man you gotta
knock that off
and so his parents were Mormon or like
Latter-Day Saints and they were
they said you can't like Pokemon anymore
because they found out there was a
psychic type of Pokemon okay they're
like nah okay
that's because that's like Devil yeah so
he had to give away all his Pokemon
cards uh-huh and he was only allowed to
have the Pikachu card
and then he had Pokemon Yellow on Game
Boy Color and he was only allowed to
have Pikachu
and he can only play up to a certain
point in the game because you needed
other types of Pokemon to like to to use
the like tm25 like to cut to cut through
a tree to go through the rest of the
game okay and he was not allowed to do
that yeah poor guy yeah
so how's he doing now I don't know he
probably has like 300 kids or something
300 little Pikachus yeah and he lives in
a mountain and yeah you know probably
have like 14 wives and he's like
foreign